so help me God congratulations mr.
president the murder report may have
found no evidence of collusion with
Russia to swing the election but Donald
Trump's legal problems haven't gone away
that's because in downtown Manhattan
federal prosecutors from the Southern
District of New York are actively
investigating the sitting president in
relation to something else entirely the
FDNY as it's known has a long track
record of going after powerful public
figures and although the office is
overseen by the Department of Justice
its lawyers have a reputation for
aggressively pursuing their cases for
being fiercely independent and for
following the facts wherever they lead
it all started last year when evidence
led the Southern District to Michael
Cohen Donald Trump's former personal
lawyer Cohen pleaded guilty among other
things to making illegal hush money
payments to two women who said they'd
had affairs with Donald Trump in the
process Cohen flipped on his old boss
I'm going to jail in part because of my
decision to help mr. Trump hide that
payment from the American people before
they voted a few days later with Cohen
as a cooperating witness the SD NY began
investigating Donald Trump his
businesses and his associates akuti
understands that you've been in contact
with the Southern District of New York
is that true I am in constant contact
with the Southern District of New York
regarding ongoing investigations Preet
Bharara until he was removed from office
when Donald Trump came to power was the
US attorney in charge of the SDN why
they wrote in the Michael Cohen
sentencing memo that Cohen acted in
coordination with and at the direction
of individual 1 and we know now that
individual 1 is the president in your
view would your former office have
written such a thing without the
evidence to prove it no I mean that's
that's the starkest statement of
criminal liability in the direction of
the President
of any other statement that I'm aware of
in the entire pendency of the Muller
investigation and the Southern District
of New York's various investigations
that's a very powerful statement of
culpability that does not necessarily
mean that if Donald Trump were an
average citizen that he would be
currently under arrest there can
sometimes be a gap between accepting a
statement like that and just in deciding
that you have enough evidence to go to
trial and prove beyond a reasonable
doubt present nighted State's guilty of
that crime because remember Michael
Cohen would be the key witness and that
in such a case Michael Cohen has lots of
credibility issues but it's a powerful
statement and it says a lot
can we go so far as to say that the SD
NY has named the President as an
unindicted co-conspirator essentially I
mean they didn't use that language but
essentially yes yes D and I put it in a
court document describing the facts as
they understood them they wouldn't do
that unless they believed it to be true
you just you don't do that you don't
adopt statements by other people unless
you believe that to be true so they
believe it to be true but the SDN wise
investigation isn't just limited to the
hush money payments it's also looking at
Donald Trump's inauguration the
committee for that event did a lot of
its work here in Trump Tower in New York
City and prosecutors are asking
questions about what happened to all the
money it raised and whether or not
foreign entities made illegal donations
this time they reportedly have a
different cooperating witness Deputy
inauguration committee chairman Rick
Gates Trump Ally Chris Christie is
concerned they have - tour guides is
what we used to call them out as a
prosecutor Michael : to take or take the
prosecutors around the business and
personal life of Donald Trump and Rick
Gates to take them around the campaign
and the inaugural you don't want to hear
prosecutors tour guides you want to make
it as difficult for them as possible to
find things out if you're being
investigated Southern District - New
York is the most perilous of the
investigations for the president because
of the people they have cooperating with
them
whatever the SDN why finds or does not
find there is a long-held Department of
Justice view that a sitting president
cannot be charged with a crime it's
unclear though what that might mean
once Donald Trump leaves office mr.
Trump denies all wrongdoing he is yet to
publicly mention the Southern District
of New York's investigation
Hannah Thomas Peter Sky News in New York